tout à l'heure le prenant un public a
fait savoir aux guadeloupéens et aux
martiniquais qu'ils suivaient leur
épreuve avec attention et émotion je
cite paul dijoux sur socata d'état aux
dom tom sera chargé dû rendre compte de
l'ampleur des pertes subies et des
mesures à prendre
et puis son conseiller à l'elysée chargé
les dom-tom ira lui aussi sur place
monsieur jean baptiste est lui-même
antilles deuxième grands dossiers de
l'actualité ce soir la journée continue
dans les lycées c'est christian bilhac
le ministre de l'éducation qui hier a
dit aux jeunes giscardiens que les
expériences allait se poursuivre et même
se développer alors devant les réactions
à cette nouvelle tentative pour
améliorer les rythmes scolaires il a été
amené aujourd'hui à prendre un petit peu
de recul nous entendons tout à l'heure
ce qu'en dit son porte parole
mais quel que soit le sort réservé à ce
projet il y à là pensons-nous matière à
débat et nous voulons ouvrir ce débat
sur un thème de alors vous devrez aussi
tout d'abord un petit condensé des
réactions des principaux protagonistes
dans cette affaire
réactions recueillies par jean jacques
duffau la journée continue au lycée ce
n'est évidemment pas encore une
révolution dans les habitudes scolaires
françaises puisqu'il ne s'agit que d'une
possibilité d' expérience offerte aux
établissements du second cycle
mais enfin la proposition du ministre
c'est déjà un pas vers ce qui existe en
allemagne ou en angleterre
apparemment et bien qu'on ne puisse leur
donner une valeur de test national
les premières réactions semble négative
pour madame cabié mère de famille
l'inquiétude prédomine que font les
enfants
la prévention est indispensable de
réformer les rythmes scolaires et
rythmes scolaires aujourd'hui ne
correspondent plus du tout à la vie en
1981 sadate 2
nous sommes en 1930 maintenant ça risque
de poser des problèmes aux mères de
famille personnellement je serais très
inquiète de savoir mes enfants livrés à
eux mêmes à partir de 13 heures
puisque il n'existe pas d'équipements
socio culturels ou sportifs qu'ils
soient leur disposition donc je crois
que en l'état ce serait inquiétant pour
les mais pour les parents pour les
familles à la difficulté avancé manque
d'infrastructures pierre bru ce ton
professeur de français à reims en ajoute
deux autres on nous informe cette mesure
tout dernier moment et je dois dire
qu'actuellement d'un établissement la
plupart des emplois du temps la
répartition d'occupation des salles de
classe est déjà terminé et je ne vois
donc pas les chefs d'établissement à
refaire tout leur emploi du temps
la deuxième raison c'est que je crois
qu'il n'y a pas les moyens matériels
pour assurer cette jolie continue
d'instruction scolaire en particulier
par la cantine très rapidement pour dire
que on assiste à une réduction des
personnels alors qu'on devrait avoir si
cette mesure était mise en place un
afflux d'élèves et d'enseignants de
l'enseignant qui participent à craquer
ça peut paraître étonnant mais le fils
et la nièce de madame cabié ne sont pas
très enthousiastes ils pensent eux aussi
qu'il y a beaucoup de problèmes à
supprimer avant de transformer cette
expérience en réalité quotidienne
par contre il précise qu'il serait
s'occuper tout seul il est très capable
de ce capital en tout cas à partir de la
seconde mais ce que je pense que c'est
un peu ambitieux de dire qu'on va être
capable de boucler les programmes en
quatre ou cinq heures par jour alors que
déjà en cette heure on a du mal à les
boucler alors si si on veut faire cette
réforme faut d'abord commencer par
raccourci quoi voir changer le programme
français parce qu'on a beaucoup plus de
travail que en allemagne par exemple
alors on à paris ils ont connu et vous
oui mais je pense
pas moi cette année par exemple j'avais
des journées complètes qui allaient
parlant de 8h à 6h30 au moins deux et
avec seulement une après-midi de livres
par semaine donc je me demande comment
est ce que l'on travaille en de de 8h à
13h on pourrait arriver à finir les
programmes qui ne sont pas toujours
finir comme ça donc le sage sanskrit
point de vue il temps il faudrait
changer les programmes aussi avec pour
que la journée continue soit un succès
il faudrait aussi changer de solides
traditions alimentaires et toutes les
autres habitudes de vie bien ancrée dans
les mentalités celle des élèves comme
celle des enseignants ou des parents